[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur rallye
fällt heute gibt es mal wieder eine
richtig schöne torte ich werde eine
wickelt orte machen mit pc schicht außen
herum dafür back ich jetzt zuerst einen
biscuit und zwar brauche ich das schoko
bis mit platten
ich mag gleich zwei gleichzeitig am ende
werde ich aber wahrscheinlich vier stück
brauchen und ich packte gleich in zwei
begriffen das heißt wenn ihr einen
backofen zu hause hat bereitet jetzt
erst mal das halbe rezepte und backt nur
ein blech im ofen nicht bei heißluft
keine zwei bleche gleichzeitig den
heißluft trocknet denn bis gut aus und
das möchte ich nicht damit er gleich
beim backen nicht reißt ich zeige euch
jetzt mal die zutaten für 2 bis mit
platten für den bizkit verwende ich 8
200 gramm zucker eine prise salz einen
teelöffel tom karonga 150 gramm mehl und
50 kommt cacau und jetzt nehme ich hier
die acht eier
die kommen in einer rührschüssel also da
ist wirklich wichtig ober unterhitze
verwenden und keine heißluft das ist so
die wichtigste message dann zucker und
salz in der schüssel geben und ihr seht
auch jetzt schon ich habe kein
backpulver im biscuit denn ich werde
jetzt die eier zucker mischung richtig
lange aufschlagen lassen hier noch tonka
bunker dazu ihr könnt auch eine
tonkabohne hinein reiben so ein bisschen
von abrieb davon
so können das aber einfach portionieren
und jetzt wirklich so etwa 15 minuten
ganz cremig verrühren
alternativ könnte aber auch ein bisschen
backpulver zum mehl dazugeben braucht
man aber beim bizkit wirklich nicht und
ohne backpulver wenn ich du bist echt
auch immer ein bisschen besser also
bankerin
[Musik]
jetzt die eier richtig schön dick cremig
ich nehme jetzt hier noch einmal und das
kakaopulver nämlich noch schön gesucht
so verbindet sich es gut und es bleiben
keine klümpchen im teig
[Musik]
jetzt wirklich gern vorsichtig
unterheben
das geht am besten mit einem schneebesen
nicht mehr lange röhren damit ihr die
eingeschlagenen luft nicht aus rheurdt
jetzt hab ich hier zwei programmen
bereits vorbereitet die sind oft blech
größe eingestellt und so könnt ihr auch
wirklich die besten biscuit platten
backen denn sie bekam die haben hier
einen rechten winkel
anders als auf so einem normalen
backofen blech und so habt ihr einfach
direkt ein schönes rechteck ich habe
jetzt in teig für den 1
und dann werden beide platten gebacken
und ich stelle dann noch mal zwei her
weil ich wirklich eine schöne hohe torte
machen möchte
vielleicht als kleinen tipp ich habe
vorher glasschüssel abgebogen und habe
jetzt die glasschüssel mit dem inhalt
auf die waage gestellt das gebe ich der
glasschüssel abgezogen und dann kann ich
nämlich den teig einfach halbieren in
dem ich die waage benutzt so sind beide
bis gebrochen nämlich gleich hoch jetzt
hier schön verstreichen und dann direkt
ab in den backofen
[Musik]
sind die ersten beiden platten gebacken
also jetzt einfach schön raus stürzen
und dann kann ich die anderen zwei
bizkit platten backen und während dieser
abkühlen ich lasse abgedeckt abkühlen
mit einem sauberen küchentuch mache ich
schon mal die creme
[Musik]
das hier ist jetzt übrigens der schwaben
trick ich habe jetzt nämlich de bizkit
platten herausgelöst und einfach den bug
rahmen umgedreht denn ich brauche nur
unten dieser kannte das heißt hier oben
direkt am park nahmen die steuern mich
jetzt hier nicht und so spare ich mir
einfach glück hier ja ich muss hier noch
zur schwäbischen hausfrau da ist doch
der morath stolz drauf
[Musik]
für die buttercreme verwende ich einen
liter milch 150 gramm zucker eine prise
salz etwas vanille extrakt 90 stärke 6 1
gelbe und 630 gramm butter okay ist denn
jetzt echt extrem viele zutaten
zumindest in großer menge eigentlich
ganz einfacher zu warten
aber da ich die torte in der höhe noch
nicht gemacht habe muss ich jetzt gucken
und bevor ich jetzt die creme zweimal
machen muss weil sie mir nicht ausreicht
mache ich gleich die große menge und
wenn es doch zu viel ist dann schreibe
ich die angepasste menge in den block
und in die app gebe ich ein bisschen
milch in einem topf rennen da kommt der
zucker dazu mit dem salz dann die stärke
das wäre jetzt nicht deutsch rap und
putting green genau mit pudding deswegen
stellt jetzt erstmal ein pudding her
kennt ihr ja auch wahrscheinlich von der
donau welle zum beispiel oder vom
bienenstich dann die eigelbe gerät und
ein extrakt
jetzt kurz die zutaten verrühren damit
sich alle klümpchen lösen und durch die
eigelbe bekommt die buttercreme dann
richtig schöne vanille fahre
vanillepudding wird ja auch mit gelben
gemacht zumindest aber ähnlich aus der
tüte zu bereit ist also so richtig
klasse vanillepudding und der
auftaktetappe farbstoffen und dass die
eigelbe wieder auch schön cremig und
wenn die türmchen dann weg sind einfach
die übrige milch aufgießen dann den herd
abschalten auf mittel hohe hitze
manchmal mache ich auch einfach höchst
wird jetzt höchste stufe
aber wenn ihr noch nicht so geübt im
pudding kochen damen lebensmittel hohe
hitze
damit euch einfach der pudding am
topfboden nicht anbrennt und jetzt
wirklich einfach schön rühren und
während den rühren dann aufkochen lassen
und dann fertig und die butter die kommt
erst später darf hier noch ein bisschen
auf zimmertemperatur kommen ach ich
jetzt eine leckere pudding
wenn es zu viele stamm löffel mir später
einfach die buttercreme okay aber dafür
sind schokolade reinmachen ist das holz
film asse perfekt einmal aufkochen
reicht auch schon bekommt man diese
ganzen vanille stückchen da drin wie
schön der aussieht und wie lecker
erreicht und jetzt streicht ihr diesen
vorgang entweder durch ein haarsieb oder
nehmt ihr so wie ich das fleißige
lieschen dass auch ein hase aber ich
kann hier drehen und spare mir einfach
das ganze mit dem kochlöffel hier direkt
in die schiffe
damit sie auch ausgeht
ich mach das jetzt auf zwei portionen da
es doch eine relativ große menge ist und
so entfernt ich einfach diese kleine
klümpchen die hier vielleicht noch
vorhanden sein können man sieht sie auch
teilweise sich hier auf dem gitter
den pudding dann durchgestrichen habe
deckt ihn einfach direkt an der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie ab so
bildet sich nämlich keine haut es gibt
jetzt die holding haut liebhaber und den
pudding haut wasser aber bei dieser
torte also für die füllung als
buttercreme ist nach haut nicht so gut
also direkt abdecken und dann auf
raumtemperatur abkühlen lassen dann geht
es gleich weiter mit
bevor es jetzt mit der buttercreme
weitergeht ich jetzt fast den boden
vergessen ich brauche noch einen notweg
boden den bereite ich aus diesen drei
zutaten zu ich nehme 100 gramm butter 40
gramm schokolade dann nehme ich immer
gerne zartbitterschokolade 150 gramm
hexe da habe ich jetzt einfach alle
reste zusammengekratzt die ich noch da
haben also spekulatius butter
spekulatius verleger übrigens unten papi
squibb und schmelz jetzt zuerst die
butter bei niedriger stufe schalten den
herd aus und nehmen dann die restwärme
für die schokolade
so bringt auch nix an und die kekse
kleine ich jetzt gesetz zwischenzeit
[Musik]
für die buttercreme verriet er jetzt die
weiche butter weiß cremig das dauert
etwa 45 minuten
und dann kommt da die abgekühlte pudding
wasser dazu esslöffel weise und dann
haben wir gleich noch schöne weiche
buttercreme in die flüssige schokolade
und butter macht kommen jetzt die kekse
schön verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir einen torten retter
da kommt eine back folie drauf und einen
tortenring den habe ich bereits auf 20
zentimeter eingestellt da fühle ich
jetzt die masse rein und drückte am
boden fest und dann kommt der not boden
in den kühlschrank und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich nämlich schon die
buttercreme weitermachen
guckt mal nicht verteilt das jetzt hier
erstmal so unternehmt ihr ein glas oder
eine burger presse zum beispiel und
können es ist schön am boden fest
drücken
das habe ich hier meine erste biscuit
platte die werde ich jetzt erstmal
halbieren
normalerweise mache ich wickle torten
immer so etwas 7 cm hoch die soll jetzt
aber extra hoch werden also halb wäre
ich sie ja
sie kommt jetzt die buttercreme drauf
[Musik]
und da habe ich immer an den rand dieser
teig karte dann können wir sie nämlich
perfekt auf die platte streichen ohne
dass eben am rand überquillt
wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr hier jetzt
noch schokostreusel drauf geben
dann habt ihr wie so eine art
stracciatella creme wenn jetzt gerade
viel besser so wäre hätte ich jetzt hier
frische himbeeren noch mit rein
diese nämlich super lecker in
kombination mit buttercreme oder
verzehrt werden zum beispiel arbeitslos
oder schokolade tour gefahren sind mir
nicht ganz so gut ständige frauen
früchte die lassen dann einfach zu viel
wasser und dania streben nicht so ganz
schön und jetzt hier die erste aufrollen
die sonne biskuitrolle wo man die torte
wird recht hoch ich kann sie nicht
aufstellen also ruhig weiter also das
wird jetzt echt ne krasse
herausforderung ein bisschen denn so
eine hohe video torte hatte ich auch
noch nicht ich lasse jetzt auch kurz da
stehen bestreichen auf die zweite platte
also einfache weiße tier würde dich
jetzt einfrieren
ich probiere das jetzt so und schlägt
jetzt den rest hier drumherum
oder habe ich nicht richtig abgemessen
ist aber nicht schlimm das kann ich
später immer noch wegschneiden bisher
habe ich jetzt zwei platten verbraucht
und ich glaube wenn ich jetzt noch eine
nehme dann hab ich
[Musik]
ok sieht echt gut aus wie ein unfall
aber jetzt kommt es hier der hohe
tortenring drumherum und der festigte
jetzt die creme enthält die torte
einfach stabil zusammen und deswegen
habe ich jetzt hier auch buttercreme
verwendet und keine quark sahne oder
eine andere leichte creme denn jetzt
wird die butter in der creme fest und
die trotte bleibt dann eben auch schön
stabil
ich stelle jetzt in den kühlschrank für
mindestens zwei stunden solltet ihr sie
jetzt auch kühlen damit einfach schön
alles westen ist und ich sie später
dekorieren und fertigstellen kann ich
habe jetzt drei platten gebraucht eines
zu viel
ein bisschen buttercreme habe ich noch
übrig also schreibe ich euch die menge
auf dem blog so dass er nur drei bis
vier monaten braucht und im prinzip ist
es halt auch ein doppeltop mit doppelt
orte also es sind wirklich 20 zentimeter
im durchmesser und fast 18 zentimeter in
der höhe und wenn ihr sagt so eine hohe
will ich gar nicht machen dann macht
wirklich einfach nur die hälfte
wo ist die so schwer
die tat ist jetzt gerade noch im
kühlschrank ist löst ja gleich raus und
mache jetzt schon mal außen herum eine
pc schicht ich glaube die passt
geschmack liegt und auch optisch
wirklich sehr gut dazu und ich mache
hier so eine art resteverwertung ich
habe jetzt hier sechs eiweiß denn für
den pudding habe ich als ex eigelbe
verwendet dann kommt etwas salz dazu und
300 gramm zucker und normalerweise also
ich mach das so ich mache jetzt bekennen
wird die hat nämlich eine hitze funktion
und ich muss jetzt die masse auf 70 grad
erhitzen für zehn minuten so sterben
eventuell salmonellen wenn sie da drin
sind und natürlich wird die masse auch
schön stabil und fest werk eine
küchenmaschine hat mit dieser funktion
macht das ganz einfach über dem
wasserbad dafür einfach wasser kochen
lassen der schüssel draufstellen und
dann mit einem elektrischen
handrührgerät oder einem stabmixer mit
einem schneebesen vorne drin einfach
zehn minuten lang rühren das ist dann
eben der gleiche effekt so ist ein
bisschen einfacher für mich sein kann
ich direkt auf 70 grad erhitzen und muss
natürlich nichts machen kann denn das
aufräumen zum beispiel
[Musik]
nach zehn minuten zeit habe ich übrigens
die temperatur unter genommen also nach
zehn minuten vom wasserbad wegnehmen und
dann die masse so lange weiteren bis c
wieder kalt ist also raumtemperatur hat
und dann ist es so wie hier fest jetzt
habe ich hier meine torte die lösung
jetzt hier raus das geht jetzt auch ohne
backformen es natürlich habe außen- und
nur den ist quizshow hoch und ich hatte
es vorhin nicht ganz richtig ausgemessen
deswegen muss ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen begradigen
ich hatte jetzt noch ein bisschen creme
übrig die streiche ich hier jetzt noch
drauf
somit hätte ich jetzt die oberfläche und
so werden jetzt auch die krümel gebunden
heißt ich kann jetzt hiermit auch am
rand einmal entlang streichen
ich brauche es jetzt einfach auf die
komplette creme das ist eine ganze
schicht jetzt fühle ich die torte kurz
so etwa 10 bis 15 minuten bis die
buttercreme fest ist und dann wird sie
fertig dekoriert
jetzt kann die torte eingestrichen
werden
schön auf der oberfläche an den seiten
[Musik]
und hier müsst ihr die torte jetzt
garnicht glattstreichen ich lasse jetzt
auch gewollt so ein bisschen fleckig
achtet nur darauf dass die butter kleben
sich nicht mehr im pc verwischt die
buttercreme so schön im inneren bleiben
ich habe es jetzt hier auch aus versehen
wieder ausgepackt dann streiche ich hier
nochmal drüber und fertig hauptsache sie
es so schön gerade noch hier oben ein
bisschen ausbessern und jetzt setze ich
sie um auf meine servierplatten dann
nehme ich jetzt ein keramik heller
[Musik]
richtige murat torte die hat er sich
übrigens auch gewünscht ihr könnt die
bahamas auch bevor sie auf streicht mit
lebensmittel verpassten einfärben
ich werde jetzt noch flambieren das ist
kein zwingender schritt das team jetzt
ehrt er optik und die bisher wasser die
karamellisiert an so ein bisschen
[Musik]
12 mouras wunsch dass sich eine torte
mit baiser außen mache es aber noch
nicht was ihnen steckt in uns was jetzt
auch erwähnen wollte ist dieses video
ist gesponsert von der zahnärztekammer
in reutlingen ich habe zeit bringen dann
wird es nicht noch gehofft server could
also liebe zahnarzt der kammer
reutlingen
hier sind eure kunden ihr gewinnt eine
woche mit murat ja wenn er herausfindet
in welchem video er genau diesen wird
schon einmal gebracht hat wie mal
gespannt ob das jemand herausfindet
wollte ich aber sage ist schon
angebracht ich finde es cool da
natürlich zucker aber man ist ja nicht
die ganz dort alleine das kaufe ich mir
dies sollte ich auch ganz schön groß
geendet hatte
dieser hoch sein ich mache das besser
sauber beim zweiten abschnitt damit die
top stürmer bleibt zwischen alter trick
der zahnärztekammer reutlingen super
ich bin aufgeregt wegen dem anschnitt
übrigens ist auch neben sponsor ist auch
der adipositas verband in münchen ist
auch der sponsor und die ist es eine
buttercreme ihnen drin ehrlich jetzt
okay ich kann das alles hängt an die
spitze und ein amerikanisches rezept ist
das thema mission amerika nichts rezept
wäre es geht in die richtung wirkt doch
schon sehr amerikanisch mit thomas
ehrlich sagen ich bin ich überrascht
dass es eigentlich gar nicht so süß ist
ehrlich jetzt nicht wirklich einfach in
der buttercreme wenig zucker nur 150
gramm um die ganze menge und außen nicht
das süße dass diese das frosting hier
außen titisee masse und innen ist
schrecklich nicht nämlich auch
freundschaften verschnitt gegessen
eigentlich weiß ich mir die torte
schmecken
und dennoch wäre mein tipp wenn gerade
früchte so ist bin ich auch paar früchte
dann cool ist das bisschen was einiges
rein zu bekommen zu haben werden in bern
stimme ich find ihn werden werden hier
mega dazu braucht schon betrieben werden
also problem ist man nicht mögen
ja ich habe die tasche packen weil du
sie wollte ja aber da gibt es so etwas
anderes als pure trainer weiß dass das
schwer ist hat die tore so hoch zu
machen also eben dieser stickel optik
wenn du deine kriegen nämlich wird die
hat nicht so schön fest das heißt die
schwierigkeit also dann erhöht sich als
schwierig ich finde von lecker
mannschaft kein ganzes stück auf jawohl
ich kann das so wie wir so romantisch
teil also auf jeden fall muss ehrlich
sagen ich bin nicht der der bitte cremt
jetzt ehrlich mit ja das ist ja mal ein
mann sitzt jetzt warte ich an ich bin
auch nicht der salat auch nicht
verständlich
ich bin der typ fleisch das sieht man
er ist nie kohlenhydrate der boden ist
auch toll
also ich finde ich finde den boden
richtig toll dass und schwäbischer boden
warum warum warum weil ich die alten
spekulatives aufgebraucht habe sparen
dreck nicht wegschmeißen verwerten
auch wenn sie schon abgenommen also ich
find auch macht es nach macht es im
sommer wenn ihr früchte habt ja ich bin
die tat und marcel freut sich weil eine
fette schokotorte steckt viel zurück
sagt ich echt also wirklich nicht zu süß
als fläche perfekt findet ihr jetzt höre
ich auf zu reden die kündigung für
zweiter ist und das rezept gibt es
natürlich wie immer in der kostenlosen
app oder auch uns komplett schon zu
gering
das ist wahrscheinlich die jahresvorrat
der gesamten fairtrade maschine football
teams nicht wirklich cool aber macht
sagt tschüss machen nikolaus games mit
dass da eine später schießt macht's gut
[Musik]